Hello everybody my name is markiplier and welcome to five things you don't know how five things work basically we go down the line and
Tell each other to (rambling) do four five things
Good intro
You can't even do one thing well
Anyway who wants to start they'll get it, I dunno
No, we do the song first
I know!
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five things you've never done in a dark alleyway
rub a penis (one) eat garbage (two) dance (three)
Pet a monkey (four) and run (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five things you've done on stage
Strip (one)
Run (two)
Say something sad (three)
Cry (four)
Eat a penis (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five different mating dances
(one)
(two)
(three)
(four)
(five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five things you would say
On your deathbed
I wish I fucked more (one)
I really wish I bought that hot air balloon (two)
I... Love you (three)
I wish my parents loved me (four)
Goodbye world (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
five things you would say in the bedroom
Fuck (one)
I'm ready (two)
Where do I put it (three)
Who the hell are you (four)
I'm not ready (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five things you'd like to rub between your toes
Socks (one)
Dirt (two) Sand (three)
People (four)
Small hands (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five things to do with your baby after their born
Drop kick it (one)
Field goal (two)
Bury it (three)
Put it back in (four)
Eat it (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Change places
Wade go
Five...
...places...
...you would secretly have sex
The Sun (one)
Your car (two)
Space (three)
Under...
...the Earth (four)
A Church (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five things to comb your hair
My sweet baby hand (one)
A baby's hand (two)
My own penis (three)
His own penis (four)
A fork..a SPORK! (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five things you want to do during an Earthquake
Run around (one)
Fucking rage (two)
Burn it (three)
Tell that Earthquake to 'go suck a dick' (four)
Be a guest on Tonight with Jimmy Fallon (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five different ways that you have dyed your hair
Sadly (one)
With blood (two)
with entrails (three)
Paint it white with cum (four)
Regretful things
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five things you'd like to tell your...
Five...
Five things you'd like to tell...
Just pick a name
I can't
Jeff
It's impossible
Just tell Jeff
Five things you'd like to tell Jeff
My name is Jeff (one)
Your name is terrible (two)
you're a meme (three)
you're adopted (four)
Your mother pays me to hang out with you (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five names for Youtuber porno
Clickbait my dick (one)
Demonetize my holes (two)
Put your sweet ad revenue in my pussy (three)
[CENSORED]
(four)
Change places
We've been next to each other
Fuck you
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five rules you'd have on your own personal island
No dicks! (one)
GO AWAY! (two)
I....
get beers (three)
I don't like spicy food (four)
I need a bone (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five pick up lines you wouldn't use
Hey, you look really pretty
we should maybe hang out some time
if you want (one)
Your Dad is fucking garbage (two)
Hey if you don't go out on a date with me
I'll kill your dog in your sleep (three)
Please
(four)
I had sex with your sister (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five different ways that you...
...like to...
...punch a child
Very hardly (one)
with both hands (two)
with my foot (three)
with both of his hands (four)
with the baby's own hands (five)
Fight things you would sell your friends for
Cocaine (one)
Bitches (two)
Concrete (three)
Sap (four)
Bloody napkins (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five best bikes
What?
Pedals (one)
Motor (two)
*quietly* People (three)
Tyres (four)
Working (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five things you would use shoelaces for other than...
....shoes
Strangle people (one)
Tie my belt (two)
Use to fish out fish (three)
Taunt people with it
with a coin at the end (four)
Use it to lure...
...someone to their death (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
Five things you'd bring with you...
...if you knew you were gonna die
The Barry Manilow Complete Collection (one)
Some food
(two)
A lot of money (three)
A gun just in case (four)
And... Jimmy Fallon (five)
(singing) Five things, Five things, Five things, Five things...Five things
That good?
Did you get everything you needed?
I...Yeah
Ok good
(from behind camera) Ah shit I wasn't recording
Don't even try that
All right, so that was five things, thank you to all of you guys
Oh are we not done?
I'm scratching my foot hang on
Thank you to all these guys for
Helping out if you want to see more of these fun improv games. Let us know in the comments all right cool. Thanks
Peace
Is it even on?